salut a tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce sixième épisode de la modernité
késako souvenez-vous entre le 4 et le 14
janvier 2011
une révolution éclate en tunisie mettant
fin au régime autoritaire de ben ali en
place depuis plusieurs décennies un
soulèvement de la population qui se
manifesta dans les rues et sur les
réseaux sociaux dans un pays où la
censure était omniprésente youtube et
dailymotion interdit pour ne citer que
quelques exemples
la prise de photographies très surveillé
les médias contrôlés et bien les
tunisiens ont de manière spontanée
utiliser un moyen de communication
évident et élémentaire l'écriture sur
les murs
très rapidement les murs de tunis se
sont couverts de graffitis slogan
plusieurs langues fresque murale
portrait peint plus un temps de mûrir
libre et sur l'un d'eux on pouvait lire
klur blanc peuple muet quand tous les
moyens de communication sont
verrouillées ou qui n'existe tout
simplement pas eh bien il faut trouver
d'autres supports n'importe quel support
les sols en goudron les murs en béton on
se retrouve alors dans une situation
semblable à celle que connut les hommes
pendant des siècles sans télévision sans
téléphone sans journaux sans ordinateur
a tunis les raisons de la contestation
elle était politiques ont critiqué le
pouvoir en place et on exigeait des
élections démocratiques via des messages
et les graffitis antigouvernementaux
mcddi el shafie un dessinateur égyptien
présenté le graphe comme le ministère de
la propagande révolutionnaire la
propagande
voilà un thème qui va nous occuper dans
cette vidéo parce que dans un tout autre
contexte ont lieu cette année en france
les élections présidentielles et bientôt
les affiches les programmes les slogans
qui sont officiels non décoreront les
murs de nos villes
et comme à chaque événement politique et
bien cet affichage officiel suscitera
des réactions de la part des citoyens
eux aussi utilisant les murs la guerre
des affiches arrive mais l'utilisation
du graffiti comme moyen de rébellion par
le peuple ou de promotion du pouvoir par
les élites
ça remonte un sacré bout de temps rien
qu'à la sonorité du mot graffitis on
peut entendre qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
phénomène émergent dans les années 80
comme on peut lire parfois littéralement
le terme graffiti ça vient du latin et
ça désigne tout gravure à l'aide d'un
stylet sur un mur ou sur un objet
oubliées donc les ruelles de new york le
métro berlinois où le quartier de
belleville à paris car le graffiti au
sens le plus commun d'écrire son nom est
de laisser une trace sur un mur ça
remonte à l'antiquité
je vais donc vous parler du cas de
pompéi cité antique du sud de l'italie
qui chaque année organisé des campagnes
électorales pour lire des magistrats et
toute la ville se mobiliser pour cet
événement mais avant de vous expliquer
plus en détail cette organisation je
tiens à préciser que toute ressemblance
avec les campagnes électorales moderne
est absolument fortuite
donc que trouve-t-on à pompéi et bien on
trouve des affiches des milliers
d'affichés pour l'instant on en connaît
à peu près de 1800 et c'est un chiffre
qu'il faudrait revoir à la hausse car
1500 d'entre elles ne concernent que la
dernière campagne électorale
ces affiches étaient en réalité des
inscriptions peintes sur les murs des
bâtiments en lettres rouges et noirs
tous les ans on recommençait et
d'ailleurs on peut voir cette
superposition ces affiches qu'on appelle
plutôt des deep in pti servait comme à
notre époque à soutenir la candidature
d'un personnage le message véhiculé se
compose de formule passe-partout du type
je vous prie de voter pour untel car il
est digne de gérer les affaires
publiques
même si dans la campagne électorale il
s'est comporté de manière opportuniste
évitant de détailler son programme
les habitudes ont la vie dure
mais que faut-il pour être candidat à
cette époque c'est-à-dire au premier
siècle de notre ère en réalité deux
choses sont essentielles
la richesse et la notoriété les
candidats ne sont élus que pour leur
qualité morale leur honnêteté les murs
de pompéi se couvrent d'inscription qui
célèbre les qualités de celui qui se
présente en somme la base de toute bonne
campagne électorale ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que l'élection à la
romaine se fait sur un nom plutôt que
sur un programme et au final tout est
affaire de confiance
bien avant les tunisiens les romains
avaient fait de la rue un lieu
stratégique pour se faire entendre
tout simplement parce que c'est le point
de rencontre obligés de tous les
habitants issus de toutes les classes
sociales
un badaud de cette époque ne pouvait pas
échapper aux injonctions multiples
d'aller voter
fais-le aller voter car déjà
l'abstentionnisme était une
préoccupation majeure est donc on
n'hésite pas à réveiller au sens
littéral du terme
les citoyens intel va voter tudors ou
quoi ces graffitis gravé à la pointe
sèche par les habitants de la ville
vienne vient souvent soutenir ou au
contraire contester la candidature d'un
personnage et tout le monde participe à
ce petit jeu les hommes les femmes les
vieillards les soula qui sont assez
nombreux pour mentionner salut à vous
nous sommes de vrais outre et il ya
également tous les commentaires qui
s'éloignent parfois du caractère
électoral mais qui témoigne quand même
de l'utilisation des murs à cette époque
on parle du militantisme avec un exemple
du même style que ce je vous ai donné
avant relis toi très bus
elie édiles l'onu fuscus cet honnête
homme pour arriver au monde des affaires
j'ai horreur des pauvres celui qui
demande quelque chose gratuitement est
un fou qu'il donne de l'argent et qu'il
reçoive sa marchandise en passant par
l'assistanat
bonjour le profit il n'y a pas de place
pour les fainéants traîna vatan pour
finir en beauté avec l'expression
courtoise et très en vogue
bapt faire crucifier l'équivalent
aujourd'hui de notre bon va te faire
[ __ ]
ça fait d'ailleurs relativisé le
sempiternel
c'était mieux avant et le fait que
l'injure serait propre à notre époque
mais qu'on se rassure la sodomie est
aujourd'hui comme la crucifixion jadis
une sentence qui est aussi administrée
par les forces de l'ordre
bon évidemment ces graffitis n'était pas
destiné à traverser les siècles puisque
les murs sur lesquels écrivaient les
auteurs étaient recouverts l'année
suivante ils ont pu se conserver grâce à
l'ensevelissement de la cité par les
cendres de l'éruption du vésuve en août
79 après jésus-christ de la même façon
que les murs de pompéi ont été des
outils de propagandes politiques ou
simples supports de communication des
habitants les murs de nos villes
modernes se couvre de messages avec
toujours cette dichotomie entre
informations officielles et critique de
ladite information sous la forme de tags
les dirigeants romains laisser les murs
des édifices publics à la disposition
des habitants car la propagande doit
être diffusé c'est sa raison d'être
en l'absence de radio ou de twitter vous
l'avez compris c'est toute la ville
qu'ont laissées libres comme support à
l'expression à notre époque en revanche
écrire sur les murs c'est une pratique
contrôler qui peut même être délictuelle
et ça constitue en soi un acte de
révolte mène un film face aux affiches
des pouvoirs en place
après ce qu'on vient de rappeler pour la
tunisie ou pour une époque bien
antérieure comme celle de pompéi et bien
on constate que les murs sont toujours
un moyen d'expression privilégié on a
encore pu le constater au sujet des
attentats terroristes en france et
ailleurs ces dernières années beaucoup
de personnes ont spontanément exprimé
leurs sentiments à l'aide de craie sur
les façades et les trottoirs
donc si on en croit le premier slogan
que je vous ai mentionné murs blancs
peuple muet cela voudrait dire que nous
sommes pourtant muet la plupart du temps
alors ce que je vais vous dire est assez
convenue mais il me semble en réalité
que nos graffiti hewitt est en partie
dématérialisée certains graffeurs
continue bien évidemment d'emmener les
murs de nos villes
mais ce sont bien souvent des artistes
qui s'y consacre à plein temps pour ce
qui est de la majorité des gens il faut
dire qu'on écrit plus forcément sur un
mur en rentrant de soirée comme le
faisait du sus il y à bientôt deux mille
ans mais on poste plutôt un petit
commentaire sur les réseaux sociaux
et d'ailleurs c'est pas anodin
que l'on nomme encore cela des murs
[Musique]